Film Courage: When did you start writing
movies? Victoria Fratz, Screenwriter/Actor: I
was in acting school and I was feeling just a
little like...I wasn't quite connecting to any
material. I felt like there was more in me that
was maybe even outside of acting and so I just
started writing. I had a friend who was writing he
recommended that I download Celtx you know Celtx
it was free at the time. I'm not sure if it still
is but I was like oh excellent. I went home and I
started just drafting up pretty much the worst
stories we will ever read today. They were not
that good. They were very boilerplate, they were
very cliche and full of just regular common tropes
which is totally fine because that's good you
you want to like start with that and and run with
just whatever is speaking to you and so that's
what i did i started writing that must have been
i want to say like four or five years ago now um
and really i've been writing ever since i really
have always always loved writing screenwriting was
new for me but i used to try and write you know in
standard like novel format all the time because
i love i love telling stories like i hope one day
to be a master storyteller and that would be my
greatest gift to be able to create stories that
you know they reach out through time and space
to people and and maybe can inspire or excite and
draw emotion and touch people you know from around
the world and um yeah i really hope to just become
a better and better storyteller as i keep writing
so you're taking this acting class it's l.a based
yes okay valley-based acting class and you
were going back and writing and you said you
were writing these very common tropes it was yeah
what were they well i mean it was really even the
entire storyline was just very cliche so i would
say i can i can give you one of them it was um
this couple who are in an uber share and
they fall in love but the guy doesn't like
her and she does not like him and but then she
somehow like somehow some property you know
gets swapped between them and they have to meet
and they realize that they do have some things in
common ah twist and uh and then they fall in love
and i had this whole scene that i wrote where she
or he's like running down sunset to like catch
the uber that she just got in i mean i'm sure in
some world that that's actually a good script
like in the hands of uh you know aaron sorkin
i'm sure it could be a brilliant he could take
that what i just announced to everybody and say
okay i'll run with this as a freaking challenge
and make something great out of it uh you know
as a project writer i did not run with it in a
very advanced way it was very like boilerplate
and so did you feel it was boilerplate or did
other people give you feedback on it that was
one where nobody really read my work then but you
know you you kind of read your work a little bit
later and you're like oh i just why did i do
this this is just so you know you see it a lot
you see it often and furthermore with
with my writing i'm always a little bit
harsh on myself as i think everyone really
should be especially if you intend to be the
one putting it in production or or if you're going
to pound the pavement and try and sell your script
be honest with yourself is this a good piece
of work are you ready to pound the pavement and
try and sell the script or are you yourself
committed to fun you know finding financing
assembling a crew putting this into production
like are you going to make it and if you are
let's start from a really solid foundation with
a script you know everything is built off of the
script so that's where that's why i'm a little bit
harsher with my my critique of my scripts because
i now i'm on the other side of that looking glass
i know exactly how much work goes into it how much
effort time money and that stuff is not like
time is priceless you know you can never get
that back so you really need to be building from
an extraordinarily strong foundation of the script
how do you know you have a good movie idea it's a
great question i think everyone wishes they knew
the answer um i don't know if you can ever know it
but i know that you can feel that we all know that
that feeling that nugget of excitement inside of
your chest and you see it clearly and you're going
absolutely absolutely i can feel it now that's
that's more intangible that's me just talking
about passion and inspiration but if you are
looking for you know maybe you're building a
marketing deck or something like that you need
to like show financials like facts that this is
a good idea i think the best thing you can do is
look for comps you know look for comparable films
and budgets and try and figure out okay this is
this is slightly similar to what i'm creating
did they have a really clearly defined marketing
strategy is it is it clearly articulated to the
end viewer what it is that i'm telling if the
tone is muddled your characters aren't defined
you might want to go back and like start you
know fine-tuning that but if you can really
you see your character so clearly you see exactly
what the tone is going to be then you're in a
good place you can keep going you can keep green
lighting yourself to the next chapter of your of
your process yeah are there other ways that you
test your ideas for something i like to do if
especially if you're maybe at a delicate stage
of your story where it's not quite ready for
peer feedback something i like to do is walk away
from the script for a little period of time you
know maybe even like a month or if you need to a
few months because you have no idea the clarity
that you'll get it's like hitting the reset button
and then when you go back to that script you're
reading through it you get to see with really
fresh eyes like okay this is this is pretty great
or or okay this needs a little bit of work but
i see what i did here and i see what i did here
let's just tighten up these bits and then
this is good to go so that's one of my little
kind of obvious tricks to do just walk away
from your project really let your brain reset
watch different genres of film read different
genres of books you know or whatever and then
go back to whatever it is you wrote and try and
look at it with the freshest die as possible
what's a film that's out there that you you wish
so much you'd written it like the dialogue is so
perfect or or even the lack of dialogue just the
just the show don't tell okay this is gonna stop
so we recently re-watched the matrix i
was on a high after watching that movie
it is the best movie ever the script
is so tight the characters you're like
and of course then there was the foreshadowing
in this scene and then of course he's going to
do this and this is and i mean i still i still
cry and like get the get the chills when you
know the helicopter scene and morpheus and stuff
oh my gosh i was in i was on cloud nine i wanted
to write like a million scripts after i re-watched
that movie um which i know is really popular maybe
so everyone's probably like yeah duh it's a great
movie but that that type of film inspires me for
for days and that's really like that gives me the
boost too to create every damn day because i watch
something like that and i think that started
out as just someone's idea um the wachowskis i
don't know but they're wachowskis they one of them
said to the other one hey how about this and then
just from them kicking the idea back and forth it
became what it is today like this incredible film
um that changed a lot of people's lives and
definitely i remember like getting on vhs and just
popping once the v8 just popped out of the tv
popping it right back in rewind i'm watching
that again i love that bill okay this is off
topic a little bit but i was at a store and
somebody's like oh they can help you and they're
like neo can you help her yeah and i was like oh
wow i bet you their mom and dad yeah because he
was young enough to be that eight you know i bet
you that's what happened he's the one he's the
one to help you exactly and he was very helpful
he was like well he's the
one victoria how protective
are you with your movie ideas fantastic question
so um i'm going to share a story in a moment
i used to write my ideas and then like you know
aaron is obviously my partner in all of our
writing and production processes and i would tell
him and you know then maybe later that day we'd
be on a walk and he would just be chatting you
know we're walking around los angeles somewhere
and he's chatting and he's like talking about
the story line and i'm going sh there are actors
and writers everywhere and producers shh like our
idea and he he was the one who told me like listen
yes it is absolutely possible that someone
can steal your idea but first of all no idea
is new like every idea is you know kind of like
coming from something else and have confidence in
your ability to create it because even when
we make when we make that idea or if we ever
make that idea it will have our stamp on it
we'll have our style on it and if someone else
can come by and take that idea and somehow
make it better than what we were going to do
then good because like ultimately i want the best
story out there i mean i'm not telling anyone to
steal my ideas please don't but you know if if
someone does uh come up with a better version of
it i'm all for it and so that's the like a few
years ago we came up with the idea for have you
seen the movie freaky within spawn okay so we
came up with that idea however many years ago
and i loved it i loved the idea i was like okay
we've got this serial killer and he's locked away
in this jail and there's this like school field
trip where the city all these like high school
kids come and you know maybe there's some like
earring that the one girl is wearing it's very
much um freaky friday meets but but instead of the
to the mom and the daughter it's a serial killer
swaps bodies with you know like a teenage girl and
that was i mean that was the idea we had come up
with years ago that's the exact synopsis of freaky
and it's you know it was just released i think
there was a producer like from the blumhouse
team who made it and you know starring vince
vaughn and i watched it and when i saw it released
some giant part of my heart was like that was our
amazing idea it was one of our tentpole ideas
because we don't we didn't have millions of
dollars to put that in production so it had to
like sit in the library of you know treatments
um so there's like some part of my heart was like
oh no i love that idea i was just waiting to make
it but then this other huge part of me that's very
realistic is like of course someone else came up
with that idea and i'm so glad that they made it
and i think it was a really fun movie i think that
perhaps a few of my details might have improved it
no i'm just kidding but i think they did a great
job and i'm happy to see it come to life so um
you know i would say for people who are worried
don't let it stop you from from sharing certainly
let it keep you open to sharing with trusted
peers and don't sweat it if you see one of your
synopsis synopsis out there in film make another
one it's okay there's a ton of ideas keep going
sure and you know all these ideas are like in
a zeitgeist and it seems like some are more timely
than others it's just kind of interesting how you
know a lot of stuff that's similar comes up around
the same time yeah so yeah exactly it's like they
could have been working on that movie for like 10
years bro i know they i'm and i'm sure like three
other filmmakers in l.a were like i also had that
idea um so it's good i'm glad to see people are
coming up with good ideas and and make making
them into a reality so i just hope that i can
come up with the next the next fun twisted creepy
thriller like that yeah i think i was hearing
that even when the writer of the exorcist was
still alive that he would call william friedkin
and say i just wish that one scene i wish i
could have changed it this is years later and and
i think that no one's ever you know totally
satisfied and there's always there's always
more to do so oh absolutely i mean what are
they one of my favorite sayings not mine but uh
artist's work is never completed only
abandoned i mean that's absolutely the truth
when can you ever walk away from something
you've poured your heart your love into
when can it ever be done to your forever liking it
can never be done to your forever liking but you
know maybe one day you need to sell that beautiful
creation and you need to go ahead and slap the
it's done sticker on it and move it off to the
distribution line and look on to the next one
you